what up reject nation greg and john here
with our friend ace our star wars expert
literally he's filming with us so late
at night when he has a star wars panel
to do at celebration so thank you for
being here buddy if you haven't watched
our episode one reaction that's up here
on the channel we're here for episode
two ace where can they follow you oh you
can follow me at squad leader race on
twitter and instagram and you can follow
my youtube channel at first cut he's got
like an adam driver voice i love it yeah
yeah it's uh something like that i wish
i had an adam driver
maybe that added driver
meant to that
guys uh full length watch alongs for you
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows we're
at the same to get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included if you don't want to do that
leave a like that would be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction for obi-wan is up
here on the channel thank you to the
prepper boys for helping us edit down
these highlights and lastly thank you to
headspace for sponsoring this video they
have a special star wars theme going on
heads which is a meditation program
yeah
and use the roof and get some
face was the first thing i started using
years ago that got me into meditation
still meditated this day so excited we
partnered up with them uh for mental
health awareness month but more on them
right after the reaction let's do the
reaction
this is one thing disney plus has
brought us is airports in the star wars
show
has such a hong kong aesthetic it is
it's cool though very uh cyberpunk if
ever i needed guidance master it's now
spendy credits
oh
that's tomorrow
oh my god rex
oh my god
is it really rex
you think rex would recognize him right
right
it's at least tamara morrison though
okay it might just be a random clone and
yeah who's not affected by order but
it's it's it's the um
it's the fibo first i want some spice
old man
i got a castle pure glitter stem and
pollution
nice how about some information
i thought he was going to say you don't
want to sell me spice
there's a jedi
he helps people
the jedi are all gone i'll take you to
him
i won't let anything happen to you
okay so camille is a gentleman
i'm sending a mother and son to your
gate you will let them through when they
arrive i'll let them understand that
they arrive
i'm not leaving your mind
okay
it's all there oh you didn't have to
that's a great scam though i'm looking
for a jedi a girl has been kidnapped i
need your help to find her 500 to locate
the girl another 300 to take you to her
goodness that light is unforgiving
what do you know of the force my friend
just there's a lot of remotes
and magnets you're gonna help me find
this girl i'm looking for yeah i'll do
it
walter white action undercover kenobi
kenobi undercover
breaking kenobi breaking kadopi kenobi
we have to cook
what are you doing back here oh what's
this
come on man
spikes understand yeah
[Music]
you're not a jedi anymore kenobi you're
just a man
you're bleeding all over my floor
everybody believes
smart
like how they just watched it
we'll see how this one plays out
i did like fleece scene there a lot more
there you go he's a much better
[Music]
wait let go of me wait she's so little
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna get you out of here
why should i trust you would you rather
stay here
keep your head down
there is a port across the city
we need to make the last transport
you have no idea what i'm risking being
here your highness
now and you'll do exactly what you're
told do you understand it's the first
time we've seen her
physical
this is really cool
it's also her first time off alderaan
yeah
whatever power you are
craving it will not change what you are
i
brought kenobi here
you will be dealt with when we return
once i've taken credit for all your hard
work she's trying to link up with uh
vader
that's what he implied right there
saying you want
want to get to the higher power do you
really think those scum can catch a jedi
i want them to squeeze him he'll reveal
himself eventually
and i will be waiting
very much john works episode now
[Music]
is a bounty hunter put this on
if anyone asks were farmers from tall
and you're my daughter granddaughter
maybe
what nothing
you're a little smart ass leo that kind
of attitude's gonna get alderaan blown
up you know that
why aren't you using a lightsaber
maybe it's because you're not really a
jedi
i read that jedi can make things float
make me float
oh my god i mean she's a little girl
pick the best time to act like it
you think the less you say the less you
give away but really it's the opposite
how old are you
10. you don't sound like you're 10. i
was thinking the same thing
he's like
why are you
talk like a full-grown adult nothing
like precocious kids you're way smarter
than that loot kid i haven't watched
he just pretends to pause
all he says is now this is
we had him look at this reward oh that's
embarrassing
sis is with the girl he'll have half of
the city on now
let's get to him first
make sure the port is shut down i want
garrison here i'm kind of hyped for this
man there's no ordinary jedi i was gonna
snowbee is the last ember of a dying age
extinguish him obi-wan is considered to
be like one of the greatest yeah
fighters
so taking it down like a bunch of bounty
hunters they don't know how rusty he is
though that's true that's true
i really love the look of this episode
yeah it's really love the look of it
there's a little sin city sprinkled in
here too it is yeah
what is that
you did lie
leia that's what you were hiding you're
the reason i'm here they took me to get
to you
you aren't a jedi your father is a very
old friend i don't believe you leia
make her float
just one little
yeah just
wait
maybe don't run around the city with
your hood down obi-wan
it's the girl
wow
[Music]
careful you run right into riva
[Music]
parkour oh damn daredevil force core
love the subtle sound designs on our
jumps
[Music]
my man
i support bad ass man
[Music]
don't let go hold on tight
use the force man
no
[Music]
come on ben
safe gwen
great catch
uh
yeah he is
rusty
oh he took the wind out of him yeah wow
he got downstairs remarkably fast
he just
floated down the other side
jedi speed
force you really are a jedi
we need to move i love it he's slowly
becoming a jedi again the entire city is
locked down it's done you need another
exit it's a cargo port it's fully
automated they won't be looking for you
there
expect me to trust you you're a criminal
have i made a few bad decisions sure do
i feel bad about it sometimes do i like
credits
yeah there's so much stuff you can buy
with
credit go to these coordinates
they'll help you from there where is he
don't
go
oh oh well they cut off
hopefully just a hand i
am history jedi
where is he ah
what did you ask you know what i'm not
gonna answer
i don't need you to
oh no
oh man
that was a bad plan kind of practice
aquaman see harry i'm glad they didn't
kill off camille if somebody is offering
us help i think we should take it now
come on what now
nothing you just remind me of someone
she died a long time ago
i'm sorry sateen
that's a really good connection though
between satine and leia
but they're talking about padme
oh it could have a little bit of both in
there
it's designed to make us have this chat
let's see how rusty he is
because he should be able to cook her
ignite it come on my dude you don't have
to worry
you're not going to die
today
they do make those sabers really
imposing lord vader will be pleased
you didn't know
no
he's alive obi-wan ah yeah he didn't
know okay
anakin skywalker is
alive
god his performance is so good i found
him we have him and i cannot risk you
losing him again
move aside guys like arguing children
watch and learn this seems like the
crappiest movie
what
oh really think i'd let you take all the
credit
damn
oh i wonder how people can fight about
this
[Music]
you're dead he's alive
are you okay
i'm just having ptsd just a moment
anakin
whoa
oh damn
yeah menacing
dude evil mcgregor is perfect
perfect
dang
can you believe the grand inquisitor is
permanently dead
i was gonna say if you look hard enough
bring them back for rebels yeah you can
hear the fans freaking out to die again
i just started rebels he does
[Laughter]
it's the first season
[Music]
he's gone get him a robot hand i
hope assume
i think it's his face man they cut his
face off yeah i know his he was his hips
were a little forward
so one of the inquisitors just has a
necklace made of severed
members
wow yeah
oh i get it because he's in that heavy
makeup
it's cool they put him in the actual
makeup yeah
eventually darth is going to gain a
bunch of weight
i want to see the series about that this
is a seat in return of the jedi natalie
holt is the
yeah composer
we should give credit to natalie natalie
holden
yeah i think i think so good good memory
on you yeah
she's great
did she do chernobyl too or is that a
different
composer who is also
not sure
if only we could
access
that's the mystery dude it's lost the
ages
i i felt like the loki score was
definitely my favorite though man
your favorite star wars score is the
legend yeah man
of the marvel shows
uh that was a really great episode let's
talk about it man yeah
all right we're mic'd up we're miked up
not professional so we're gonna be
talking about this i'm excited to get
your thoughts i'm half excited to get
your thoughts you know you can hear my
thoughts anytime but i'm most excited to
share my thoughts
because i'm a narcissist anyway guys uh
yeah we're gonna hop into this with
better audio but before that a word from
our sponsor who again very honored to be
partnering up with them because
headspace really helped change my life
we want to thank today's video sponsor
headspace now you guys might have heard
me say from time to time that i meditate
regularly and it all first started with
this app headspace and it's an app that
i know john actually uses regularly now
thanks to me right it's all your fault
and so for this month they have
partnered up with disney star wars for
your find your force mindfulness series
which i think actually works in
conjunction with the way of the jedi so
well literally meditation has changed my
life i can confidently say head space is
a major contribution to that factor so
i'm excited that we're finally
partnering up with them especially
considering it's mental health awareness
month plus it's perfect timing because
we've got a ton of new star wars content
on the horizon and with their find your
force series they have sleep cast
breathing exercises and guided
meditations from some of your favorite
star wars characters including yoda
chewbacca r2d2 the list goes on you know
i've opened up about my prior diagnosis
in the past the most helpful thing has
been meditation it's something i very
much heavily encouraged one step closer
to feeling like a calm confident jedi so
if you want to download headspace and
find your force today head on down to
our link in the description box download
the app and get meditating do some deep
breathing hang out with yoda in all
sincerity it is pretty cool to be
partnered up with an ad that can
sincerely say help change my
oh really
you guys want to work with us that's
crazy
um
yeah uh ace why don't why don't you kick
it off man what's the first thing you
want well we'll kind of like combine a
little maybe uh kind of bleeding over
from episode one
not not not a phantom menace you know
episode one of this but yeah
yeah i mean would you we could do both
what have phantom
yeah why not why don't we review all the
prequels
and then go into this let's do the whole
thing this is a big package
uh yeah i mean what are you thinking of
uh what do you think of the show so far
i'm really digging it man i mean
to me it's
trying to set everything up for one
story
and i kind of
i mean obviously we talked about the
bait and switch back in episode one with
the olea thing
but i like that being the initiating
point or the start-up point to kind of
take us
yeah
to kind of take us where i loved your
reaction though
yeah hold it closer please
uh
i like that being the
starting point to where we're headed
which is eventually a confrontation with
vader obviously between obi-wan and
vader him finding out that
anakin
is alive and anakin is later
they're all together in one and that
this is all set up for him to be
you know confronted with that
failure
um
so i i i like where we're going there's
obviously some things that i'm a little
you know
questioning eyebrow eyebrow razor like
what
i feel like
i'm not sure about
reva
i mean to me it's more like the
character or the actor it's not even i
think it's the character because to me
it's more like
we get a little bit of backstory as far
as i hinted a backstory with the grand
inquisitor telling her that she belongs
somewhere else
so there's hints at you know a potential
connection between her and the jedi and
something like that
but to me
the final scene
with her
killing the grand inquisitor
even though we know obviously that he's
in rebels
and then her saying that anakin is alive
and he's oh and he's vader
kind of
i don't want to say rub me the wrong way
but kind of made me go huh
cause i did for me too because to me
it's always been
it's not necessarily like everyone in
the empire knows like oh that was anakin
that's that was he used to be anakin
back in the day like people don't
you guys know each other you were his
buddy
look at him now he's vader he's bossing
us around freaking freaking vader
you talk to him for us
but it's not a well-known thing you're
not supposed to know that like that's
supposed to be like a luke
obi-wan kind of thing for
but maybe i'm wrong i mean from my
knowledge i don't feel like that's
supposed to i anakin is dead like he's
dead to everyone in the galaxy and and
vader is is a completely different
person well i mean i think what they're
also doing is sort of transitioning
anakin even though it's been 10 years
right 10 years yes that they're still
transitioning anakin into
full-blown darth vader because
riva specifically cites that she's
looking that and that that vader's been
looking for him
so
i imagine that maybe vader or anakin is
still there
you know because by the time you meet
him in in episode four and stuff he's
like he's just full-blown vader he's not
anakin anymore so i imagine that he's
probably wants a little bit of revenge
for what's happened to him and you know
his kids they probably blame i don't
know exactly what his motives are but to
bring hayden christensen back and not
just a guy in a suit to get james earl
jones to be imposing vader
i feel like there's there's got to be
some type of emotional grudge
that he holds against him
and so i think there's still a bit of a
transition but i don't know why he would
open up to riva or whatever something or
what what who riva really is
honestly there are times where they're
acting that i i don't fully buy it's
really when she's getting like hyper
aggressive
or that or yelling that i'm like it just
doesn't i just don't you don't sound
believable to me i i i the thing that
makes you the most uncomfortable too
honestly is sliding someone's acting i
feel so because acting is such a
vulnerable thing and you got all these
people looking at you and watching you
when you're filming and you're putting
yourself out there so i i actually get
really uncomfortable saying that i have
a hard time believing her in
not every scene there are a lot some
scenes i think she does a a really great
job in but there's there's also quite a
bit where i'm like yeah i don't really
buy you
so that's that's my weirdest issue with
with riva i think with grand inquisitor
what you were touching on
that's something i think should have
been earned late that moment should have
been earned in like a later episode not
that i wanted to start talking about
negatives because there's a lot i love
about this there's there's so much i
love about this um but yeah with the
grand inquisitor it's
like that's something that a moment like
that should have been built up better as
opposed to them like bickering like
children for two episodes yeah and then
you you do that and it kind of is
undercutting like his from the very
first scene he had she kind of just
undercuts him and i get that's their
dynamic but then to do like fake out
death you know if you haven't seen
rebels fake out
um
that
something about that just didn't feel
like earned in this moment it is more of
like a
well it makes you wish you could see you
can see a little more from riva's
perspective if they're gonna do that
because i feel like in one breath it
kind of builds up her menace and her
ability but i feel like if we maybe
could see
a hint doesn't build up the grinding but
we don't this is an inquisitor for the
first time for a lot of people yeah so
it is for me yeah so so it's like what
is what makes the inquisitor grand you
know yeah he's just got an attitude
speeches in his voice he's just got the
title and the title is the scary part
it's the way he speaks yeah if we could
see into and i know you don't have all
the time to do all the things but if we
could see more into their friction and
their dynamic and what really motivates
the two of them yes see the grand
inquisitor and why he is to be feared
the way he is and then get that i think
it would work it made me intrigued to
see what i i can only imagine it
suggests to me
that she and anakin must have some kind
of connection he must have entrusted her
with this and so in that moment it
didn't really vex me that she would give
out that information because it seemed
like okay there's a reason why the show
has been so bold about you just not
giving a single flip about anything the
rest of your team is doing
um but yeah i actually i i've quite
enjoyed her performance from top to
bottom so i i hope that that story keeps
progressing
uh in an interesting way because yeah i
mean right now it's mostly just been
plot i like her parkour scenes oh very
cool it's great i love the sound design
they use on them too like to always
indicate she's using like four it kind
of reminds me like the video games when
you play as like a jedi yeah and so
whooshing sounds yeah yeah it feels very
much like a video game and parts of her
character
you play jedi i fell in order i'm
assuming yes what is the who's the
villain in that the not the villain but
the sister in that yeah trilla trilla
yeah there are parts i don't think it's
trilla who she's obviously not but there
are parts of her character that remind
me and and the position she plays
very much so uh so yeah i really like i
really like like i said it's not always
but there are some scenes that kind of
do rub me a little bit wrong with the
thing that's really saving this show for
me in every aspect not even saving that
sounds like the show's bad and it's
being
the thing i really love about this show
like i thought this episode i liked uh
more than episode two
um
but the thing i love most that is most
rewarding
is something that i mean this is a big
letdown for people with book of boba
fett for example i think this is really
the best thing about this at this show
is ewan mcgregor he is amazing here and
this whole thing with him getting in
tune with the force
um again like so repressed something
like we talked a lot about it in the
last review but just to reiterate a
couple of those points of this man who's
just so much in pain and so much guilt
so traumatized by everything that's
that's happening he wears that pain so
much and he's there's
he
there's such a resistance to things and
he's cut himself off from the force so
much and it's like him slow as he it's
it's kind of like obi-wan rising is is
what's happening here to the point where
he can become like the ben kenobi alec
mcginnis that you see in a new hope
where he is in tune with the force he
can do the whole like let us pass you
know the force wave thing he can do all
that
um but it's like a good wandering nomad
type of character but not one who's just
like like just
damaged everywhere he walks
uh so i i think that's been great
thoughts thoughts i feel like that's
what's great about the show is the show
is called obi-wan kenobi
and thank god he's delivering every
single time he's on the screen and it's
great because his character
has so much there as far as his
emotion his connection to the force his
disconnect to the force um his feelings
to galactic
political issues to the jedi everything
is there as far as the character of
obi-wan and i think that is like
the biggest selling factor of the show
and it's so far it's delivering in every
single aspect so to me i can look past
like a few little
nitpicky stuff
like inquisitor drama and and just
really focus on
this guy who
if anyone has seen clone wars i mean
obviously if you see the prequels i mean
you know who obi-wan is and they even
kind of hinted at it i kind of like that
little line and i was talking over it a
little bit sorry um but it was when the
grand inquisitor said
like you know this is obi-wan so like be
on be ready or be on your feet like i
forgot he's exactly what he said but he
said like this guy's different like
fiercest jedi in the game yeah like this
isn't the safety brother jedi
this is uh this is like one of the
greatest jedi's ever like this guy's
like top three top four right up there
with mason uh and yoda and they even
said it in episode one with that setup
as far as anakin recalling his line and
attacking the clones when he said he's
as
powerful as master mace and uh as wise
as master yoda
uh and then the prequels alone he beats
anakin and he beats him yeah and he
cooks him he cooks general grievous
beats he kicks his ass like obi wants
like a badass like a straight up badass
like in the clone wars he fights off
mandalorians he fights off maul and
savage and i appreciate like i watch the
movie i like i like this like 90s action
movie thing of a guy who's been out of
the game and forced to get back
and has to protect little girl you know
like it's such a
professional a lot of it's not even just
a nice action thing this is a very
common action storyline of a guy pulled
back into the field that he's protecting
a kid you know like that's a very common
action storyline
but what i really like is they are
really earning
or slowly building him being able to be
full full jedi again or fully skilled
because you know a lot of movies
it usually takes them like one fight
scene to just be a little rusty then
they're back in the game we're here i'm
like oh he is so rusty like he almost
let leo die like yeah he is wildly rusty
that that that shocked me definitely for
sure because i mean
again if you've seen anything as far as
clone wars or even the prequels go
he's his force abilities are like hella
strong like obi-wan's got like super
powerful abilities and he he's like
20 pounds of leo
and it's just like really man like come
on
bro put your back into it yeah
that's true yeah
yeah i mean i i appreciate it a lot yeah
what do you think about the direction
johnny i've liked the direction quite a
bit i mean it's um
i think it's got a really really locked
in sense of style and it's got a smooth
i mean you mentioned in the last one it
kind of oscillating between movie and tv
show kind of feel and i thought this one
felt more unified
as a more cinematic yeah more cinematic
generally and i think like i i really
like what deborah chow's been doing
overall behind the camera like i think i
mean one of my favorite aspects of all
of these expansions is often that tone
that ineffable star wars tone that is
bolstered by so many things like music
and and visual motifs and
you know
beloved characters animatronics blah
blah blah but you know to go into this
and to have an uh daiyu another place
that's newish and you know can bring
some aesthetics that evoke some other
things like it's fun to look at these
things and not only have all the easter
eggs but also be able to look at other
movies and say okay there's a little bit
of sin city here there's a little bit of
blade runner here and uh and like you
said even like the classic kind of it's
like obi-wan the professional
you know uh and
yeah i'm i'm curious to see how it
builds and increases momentum because i
feel like right now it is a very plot
oriented show like there's some really
nice emotional beats and i just want to
walk around more in that stuff because
when uh you know they're balancing and
this is credit to the direction like
there are times when it's balancing an
action scene with just you know emoting
emotive acting from ewan mcgregor and
both are just as potent and i would love
for the rest of the writing to kind of
encompass that dynamic because i feel
like it's really there in the direction
i'm trying to figure out what the
definitive tone of the show is that's
something because it's like they feel so
different these two episodes but they're
so tethered at the same time it's like
so serial
um
whereas like mandalorian seem to like
nail its tone right away like you know
that you can literally just cue that
song
with that flute and you're like that's
the tone of the mandalorian right there
that's the mandalorian um whereas like
the tone here i'm like what is the exact
tone and the definitive pace of the show
because there are some things i love i
love the direction with like the way
they handle the lightsabers like you've
pointed out there's such a menace to it
um
i think i think like the show is yet to
bro approach yeah okay i'm going with
that word is yet to get to the point of
what the trailers elicited for me like
the trailers elicited such like a
like a
cinematic freaking uh
introspective tone poem heavy
um like you're really gonna overrate
this character and feel this
transformation yeah yeah it hasn't quite
reached
that yet for me it still seems like it's
a bit at odds with being that show and
fun it it paid i feel like it in a lot
of ways looks and paces and behaves like
that
but i wanted to speak like that
right i feel like in the writing they
could do more character
for the amount of plot like it does feel
for as cinematic as aspects of it are
very kind of straightforward in a sense
in a way that i'm a little surprised by
i guess fight us ace
well i mean i i just think it's early i
just think it's a little it's a little
it's a little early so
it's been 90 minutes
we are a third of the way through this
i'm in act one
it's two episodes down
we got a lot of time we gotta we got a
lot of episodes i feel like we can reach
that by the time we get through
the final episodes and i think once we
get more hayden christensen and there
will be a whole other level perhaps that
the show will go to
yeah i i want to ask you guys obviously
there's so much i want to ask you guys
just because i want to hear your
perspectives um
obviously we see that final scene with
obi-wan awaking anakin as he says anakin
and he responds to it i just think it's
funny he responds to it when when
obviously if you've seen rebels and if
you see any other media darth vader just
basically killed anakin in his brain
like it's it's like a person he doesn't
acknowledge it's like a completely
different person so the fact that he
awoke as soon as obi-wan called him out
in the force
almost like calling to him
uh was something that was interesting to
me because to me it was like oh he's
responding to his old name which is
anakin but rebels was later it is later
it's true but but i feel like that's
something that he
took on
pretty early on after revenge of the
sith but again i'm not sure exactly how
early on but how do you feel about him
being in
the makeup and having hidden christensen
act through
through that is is that i think that's a
gift for a performer i think that allows
you to like when you have all that
makeup
usually for an actor that that is a gift
because it allows you to lean into that
so i'm i'm
curious if he's just going to sound like
hayden christensen
he's got the darth vader breathing
um you know like when he talks what's he
gonna say like because you know i mean
even in return of the jedi when the mask
is off he sounds it sounds different so
he's not gonna have james turtle jones
voice
um so i think it would probably
oscillate between the two when he and he
is uh but i i'm excited for it i feel
like there's a lot to impact because i
think what even what even mcgregor is
doing is something that is so much more
emotionally stilted than i was expecting
like he does
he there's so much of just getting
stopped in his tracks and contemplating
with his eyes
like when he learns that information
about anakin you know that it's just so
such a mood there's such such a haunting
moment
and it's like it just makes you start
the my brain starts firing and this just
feeds into what you're asking about it
starts firing with my god um
like what is he feeling in this moment
like it's got to be a combination of
fear
guilt worry and
maybe there's hope a chance he wants to
reach out to me like there's so many
layers to that reaction that that was
that's the [ __ ] about this show that i'm
loving the most when they just let the
camera sit
and do it and let the actors in the
world do its job because in that moment
i was like that is some of the that's
like brilliant acting because you got
all kinds of conflicting emotions
reading across his face
it's not just like i gotta [ __ ] this guy
up you know it's it's all these
different emotions that you could see
even mcgregor experiencing
um
and also being triggered so
yeah i think like i'm excited to see
it's been washington's hannah
christensen see if you mcgregor is doing
this good of a job like what are these
two performers gonna do servicing each
other in the scene is what i'm looking
forward to most
um how do you feel about it no i mean i
i'm still i'm still pumped i'm just
curious if we're gonna see
you know more of the makeup more of him
behind the mask
more maybe even a flashback
uh which has been rumored uh but
obviously nothing confirmed or did you
get jake lloyd back yeah you should
dhj
yeah that's great shrinks that will do
wonders for everyone
but i feel like you know
you don't necessarily bring back hayden
if it is just to be
you know that brief moment that we saw
him and i i think we we're gonna be a
full character yeah we we we definitely
have to see more for sure to me kind of
going back to to the tone of the show
and kind of going back to
what the show is accomplishing so far in
this episode
i think star wars has always reached
that
both balance but also kind of
disconnect when it comes to goofy
and serious
and and if you watch it and i can
really pinpoint this as a mega mega star
wars fan who's seen the movies too many
times
there's every single movie has
a lot of super ridiculously goofy
moments even empire strikes back you
guys can rewatch that one
and at the same time has some really
deep and dense and dark stuff so
i feel like so far the show is doing a
really good job of showing us the dark
deepness with obi-wan and then trying to
goof it up a little bit with kumail
with leia doing a little like you know
running off on her own like i love
kumail yeah i thought camille was great
he was he was he was a
wonderful welcome addition i was half
hoping it was a real jedi too i really
like that would be a funny take on a
jedi yeah and i'd be on board piss a lot
of people off but yeah i would still be
on board how could this guy be that
balance if he's yeah but i like the gray
of him too like he's not
he's a con man sure
um but at the same time he's you know
he's still got a heart you know like he
just wants to make money but you know
when it comes down to it if he's gotta
do the right thing he's gonna do the
right thing so i thought i thought he
was a great performer and i loved like
even that moment i think deborah chow
was like a
actor's director
you know we you can see it in the most
subtle moments of of like when the when
the
when when riva
uh reads his mind on where obi-wan is
and you just see this like shame come
across kumail's face
of like i would i was supposed to
protect him that was the whole purpose
and now i've done the exact opposite
uh i thought was a really strong moment
uh for for kumail nanjiani
leia is a cute little girl a little
adorable little brat precocious little
one the most precocious thing i've ever
seen
yeah i i want to
hear the the song like one way
i'm going to find you she's just obi-wan
chasing after her i'm gonna get you get
you
just like waddling someone's gonna make
that super cut online because she
waddles like the little girl like it's
like a cute little like penguin waddle i
don't know if you guys caught that
but i was just like waddling
i was like this is hysterical there
there are times though where i could use
a little bit of a tad bit more nuance
with the writing sure there are times
where i i do crave it
i'm like she's this one solid note of
this of this portrayal of this girl
she's snapping at obi-wan she's snappy
doesn't seem
is is wildly fearless yeah like so to
the point where i'm like you can't be a
real
girl like you this is your first time
off alderaan
you're in the slumps
in the worst planet ever apparently
and you're just like
it's like there are times that i feel
like there's
there's not enough reactant reactiveness
towards
out of you know like things that are
truly like if you're not feeling
threatened at all it's hard for me to
feel worried for you whatsoever but but
i feel like that
the way they set up the planet to me and
i think john was getting added too was
was really well done as far as
showing all the creatures even even the
side characters that had like two lines
like that little girl who was like you
want to buy spice and and then she was
like oh give up on the girl whatever
like she felt kind of authentic i
thought she was great yeah i think the
world they built was great i mean like
you don't you don't get words like that
in the other live action shows a little
bit of mandalorian it's what we crave
from boba fett
and you get something you get these kind
of worlds and like clone wars and stuff
um but to get it here
i think that's one of the like that's
why i really like this one more than the
other one because this is
actually like oh this is different yeah
this is cool to see yeah the creature
effects were cool um we saw a lot of uh
you know background characters that
if you name them all later i know you're
here there was name one checklist
breakdown specifically
uh it's like very specific um
no but there's a there's a character in
there that i i want to say is called
weasley but i might be wrong no i i
think i'm wrong moment of truth sound
like a goddamn idiot
but it's the one where i think it is we
asleep from a new hope
um which is the many-eyed
creature
um and there's also oh yeah i know talk
about it yeah i don't know
the one who bought the speeder
um
off luke skywalker
but there was a lot of cool like
moments in there for like
for like a new rock stars
[Laughter]
paws and frames like look at that
creature look at it eric boss knows he's
all off the top of his head
if you pause right here at 22 seconds
there was no research
he never he knows that all of these
videos are improv
shout out to new rockstars
what up boss he's a celebration right
now yeah i i you know it's a cool moment
for star wars fans to see all those cool
creatures yeah and creature effects
behind the scenes and i felt like the
world building there as i mentioned that
little girl who was trying to sell spice
i was joking around as far as the death
sticks i'm sorry i i it was a very
serious moment that little girl i'm glad
i was waiting for this whole time for
you to apologize about it yeah
the guy who got excited to see the
youngling slaughtered yeah
love it and uh i was like oh this is a
destix moment and i was like no it's not
i mean uh i i i there's a quality here
that i'm really appreciating
which is something i've wanted to see
explored a little bit more and i like
that they're capturing it through the
wonder of little leia which is the
droids are
life they're alive
and
so much of the time they're just like
disregarded but they're actual beings
you know in this in the star wars world
and and sometimes you get characters you
treat them like actual beings and
sometimes you get characters you treat
them like they're robots
and i really like how leia captures that
wonder of no this is this is a
there's a real per there's a real this
is my friend there's a real soul here
you know
which kind of
feeds into the whole thing of like
entrusting r2d2 down the road
with uh you know sending transmitting a
message to obi-wan kenobi it's also yeah
i mean obviously that connects to leia
and i think of of
obi-wan's connection to george which is
not not a positive one uh from what
we've seen as far as what i've seen or
what i remember uh rip r4 not not a big
reaction when r4 died that was uh that's
obi-wan's astromech droid r4 p17 uh as
soon as he dies remember those numbers
[Music]
it's it's iconic because it's a joy that
he's been with for like 10 years and he
dies in revenge of the sith with the
buzz joints and he's just like oh my and
he's just literally that's his only line
in reaction to it um and there's also uh
oh my uh
attacking the clones his speech with uh
with a dexter jetster
where he's launched my memory here where
dexter jester is talking about uh the
droids and the jedi temple
uh reading symbols instead of the little
cup marks on the toxic dart vague
memories yeah and he's like well if
choice could think there'd be none of us
here yeah so
freaking obi-wan racist
droid is not a fan of droids
to be fair there was a droid shooting at
him
this episode droid bounty hunter dude
it's more morrison your man's been yeah
oh he
sure had a cameo here
he sure put on a beard and sat down for
an hour or two if you're getting some
more abortion doesn't do as much as you
think you you i got so excited i was
like oh my man's back i'm cool nice nod
i'm glad that you guys were on the same
sound stage why didn't they make him
like a rex or something i thought he
would have been so much more engaging
i thought he was rex at first i i can't
lie i don't blame you for thinking he
was rex at first and then it looked like
he had the uh
the uh 501st clone army
that clung gruesome hair man
because that's the uh the clone regiment
that's assigned to general skywalker
i mean the clone wars i love how he just
stays in the
he stays in the club now i mean i mean
if that's all you got
nothing but the um nothing but the armor
on my back
and so he just stays in that yeah
yeah man
i mean i just like one thing that stood
out to me from something you said
earlier that i think is perhaps
i can envision being the sort of most
gripping emotional core of this is you
mentioned the idea that you know we get
to a point where anakin is dead in
vader's minds is you know a complete
excision or thing of the past and i feel
like we meet obi-wan here in a position
where he is kind of grappling with doing
the same thing to obi-wan and just
continuing on as ben and so i feel like
that is a nice complementary internal
struggle for both characters because you
know this you know there's going to be a
flint spark when they both get back
together and you know that their reunion
will probably you know thrust is going
to thrust vader down that path of
killing anakin fully within
and i think you know it's going to
thrust obi-wan into kind of learning i
guess
the role of ben in the life of obi-wan
but what is most exciting about that to
me is the idea that we'll probably see
that conflict and those shades of anakin
that are still left over
and and see that you know through the
transformed
physical like because i keep thinking
like every time we hear about hayden
christensen and his involvement i always
think of the hayden christensen i
remember and it hit me watching this
that oh no no this is going to be like a
fresh it's going to almost be like he's
playing a new character even though it's
built on top of
all of this history and so i feel like
that's the thing was like while this
start has been like pretty decent to me
like i'm into it and i'm excited to see
where it goes i feel like that's the
stuff where i'm like once we get to
there i could see this really uh
ascending and transcending and really
starting to sing uh from where we are
now well kind of going you know big star
wars brain mode uh in a new hope
obviously this is all canon
we can debate inquisitor stuff whatever
uh also we can debate the whole anakin
you know revla stuff as well as far as
like how does she know that
but
last time
we saw them together in a new hope i
mean the first time we see them in a new
hope obviously he has that famous line
as far as like you know
you were the master now i'm the master
you know that whole speech that he gave
him as far as like the last time we met
yeah
i am the captain now uh which kind of
goes to show that like
obi-wan still kicked his ass right so
are we going to see him
kick
vader's ass
yeah because that's the question that i
have down the line because we see that
he's a little rusty but this is like
obi-wan like obi-wan cooks people
cooks them i mean they're gonna be
building to that fight and they said
they're gonna have another fight
yeah so and then obviously again i know
i keep bringing up rebels i'm sorry you
guys but in rebels he like beats maul in
like one strike because he's just like
i'm freaking obi-wan
yeah one of these episodes will be a
montage of just him training i was going
to say thor loving thunder yeah
and then it'll end with him shaving his
beard
i i feel like he would have to win um
let's say there's another there's
another line in a new hope about the
tremor and it was that he says a tremor
in the force yeah something like that
and i think that's kind of what maybe
that was that what that moment was
what we just saw oh yeah with it with
anakin and being in the
it could have just been a transition to
a match cut transition or it was him
sensing anakin
it was i feel like it was i feel like
that's what they're what they're hinting
at
i'm excited for them yeah if anything
what this is doing is really
allowing them a redemption a new
association for star wars and love for
it you know that they rightfully have
earned and uh
like
look this is better than the prequels to
me already all right
that's some big words man i think that's
hard that's hard to fight
one and two i would say uh
and i like i i don't the only star wars
movie
i truly don't like really is episode
return of the jedi whoa
don't like phantom mess wow i know a lot
of people hurts i know the the common
one is
attack of the clones
is the one that a lot of people don't
like i prefer attack of the group i mean
i i love all three but i love phantom
menace man phantom menace is like one of
my all-time favorites i mean i
appreciate when i hear like
thematically it's really what it
represents in the world like i like maul
i like
i love the context and the purpose
it serves
i don't enjoy my experience of the
actual film that it is that's my
but attack of the clones i i actually
enjoy revenge of this
revenge of the sith i think is a
genuinely great a great movie i i love
revenge of the set yeah that's a great
film
empire hands down the worst empire is
boring and overrated
and last jedi number one my ranking of
all the star wars films goes in reverse
release order yeah number one rises
skywalker two last jedi at the very
bottom we got a new hope
i swear man it's you guys invited like
the the one star wars fan who likes all
the star wars movies that's why i want
you to be here that's the business we
want that enthusiasm because that's rare
so it's star wars communities so if you
don't like something i'm like that must
not be that good
no i'm not taking the crap out of this
if there's a thing you don't like that
i'm gonna be if there's like a moment
you don't like i'll be like i'm gonna
write that down
it's the worst moment in star wars
moments star wars history oh my gosh i
swear i'm digging this i i just felt
like that i got a reputation to preserve
i swear i love showers i swear
everything about this show it's perfect
no because to me to me i just i don't
want to be like
i feel like let's i want to give moses
ingram a chance uh as far as her
character goes and that character shot
oh yeah i mean that's why i feel bad
whenever i say i have a hard time
believing it because it sounds like i'm
saying you're a bad actor so i'm like no
i'm not saying that i'm just i think
there's acting in star wars have a
dubious relationship sure
yeah i feel like that's fair because
obviously we have liam neeson in there
too and a lot of people didn't say he
was that great even though it's liam
neeson i mean now the department is one
of the natalie best actors of all time
yeah i don't think she's decorating the
prequels yeah so what you guys are
talking about
i think she's great
but but i feel like one of those things
where it's like
there is
the tv
aspect of star wars has been
it's beloved already with the man lauren
boba fett i think they just kicked it
off so strong with mandalorian yeah this
is so cinematic you know it and it's
great but i feel like they're still
trying to get a foothold as far as like
where they want to be
tone wise and where they want to be
story because i feel like at least the
movies say what you want of the prequels
or the sequels
they know what they're trying to do and
you're trying to communicate as far as
tone
story
talking to the wrong man
i've never read my review of the razor
skywalker did you like it i freaking
loved it
i liked it more than most people i don't
love it i love it i think it's great i
feel like they're still figuring out
i see you guys most people don't get
this far don't worry if you got this far
i swear i promise you you'll find at
least like 10 50 people who are gonna be
like i hate this guy he likes star wars
dude people hate me for whatever i don't
know star wars star wars is easily the
the the the community that
i will get the
so i like this little lineup we have
here yeah hardcore lover yeah i love it
and um
you seem to be liking this more than me
that is pretty decent
[Laughter]
i'm waiting for it
i have mostly pleasant feelings but i'm
waiting for it to really like kick into
a gear that i'm like yeah i can't wait i
think i think what's funny is generally
what you've seen us react to together
john generally seems to kind of be more
into it than myself
yet i know star wars more than john
which i find funny about our dynamic
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you guys watch a lot of a lot of good
shows though right a lot of quality
that's why this show is good
yeah
but it's not all the other shows
this ain't breaking bad this isn't
better call saul
well i mean i feel like if you do a lot
of tv watching reacting it might like i
don't know maybe you can rank it in a
different version in your head well i
mean it's not really comparison
we watch so much different types that
it's easy to adjust to yeah
compartmentalize yeah no it's real it's
so easy to adjust
we'll have to like watch different shows
all the time in the same day yeah
it's really easy to just switch modes
yeah well in star wars it's fascinating
because i feel like oftentimes when
you're dipping into it you're dipping in
on multiple levels because there is
to me a big picture of star wars and
there is the minutia of star wars and i
feel like they
exude the most confidence to me when
they're diving into some minutia and
it's always the big picture where i'm
like i don't know if you all
fully know what you want
and you know because there's been all
that stuff lately about like well we've
learned from solo we could just never
recast any of these characters with
other actors whereas like that's what
we're watching right now is that
happened but it was more agreeable
because clearly it's not a singular rule
and so like something like this i'm
waiting to see all the way through
because i'm wondering like right now
in a big picture sense i'm still not
sure what this show is exactly doing
aside from like literally filling in
historical gaps
but in the minutia is where it gets me
excited and where you know moments shine
out that i'm like that's really cool and
i hope they build on it you know well i
think i think the the main thing about
obi-wan is is the best like the plot
stuff surrounding obi-wan the character
is more of where i have that question
mark that you're bringing up but in
terms of obi-wan the character that's
the stuff that i i really appreciate
that they're they're fleshing out it's
like
this guy had a you know after episode
three
which was the worst experience of his
life
then you hop into episode four he's like
otherwise than that you know
i went through a whole lot but this is
you're watching him do the grieving yeah
you know you're watching him
handle like how he got to that but it's
not it's to me it's more than just a gap
i'm like this is a
like specifically obi-wan the character
not the other surrounding stuff but
obi-wan the character this is so
such an important chapter in his life
of
how did he
keep faith in all this and i feel like
and i feel like that's what we're we're
building up to already with episode one
as far as
the qui-gon stuff we get a little tease
as far as that goes talk to me goose uh
we we get a little bit of uh you don't
know they're right here
can we just i just want to take a moment
to say
i i want a tom cruise star war
i want tom cruise in the universe i
don't know if i walk in the galaxy far
far away i don't know if i can sign off
on
the poorest people
but but i feel like we're leading up to
like you said i feel like this is more
of a character exploration everything
else surrounding the character
doesn't have to necessarily be
spectacular for me but as long as the
character
gets a little bit more deeper as far as
his connection to the force because
being a force ghost is actually like
being more connected to the floor that's
a big deal so we see him being so
disconnected and we know that eventually
he becomes one of the few people who
becomes a force ghost which is not
you know which is a very rare ability
yeah which i feel like a lot of people
from the outside like i had to learn
that you know like that it's not just
like oh you die and then you become a
force because like no it's like very
special circumstance
much you know intent and much you know
melding to and and meditating on the
force yeah but yeah guys um we got to
get these videos to you guys so we're
going to wrap this
tom you're watching this
you've seen all the stranger things
we just want to give you time
uh but thank you guys for being here
thanks ace for joining us on this on
this weekly adventure man
um
and uh appreciate your insights and
thanks to headspace for sponsoring this
video and we will see you all
next week or if you want to watch more
videos we upload constantly so we'll see
you guys every day
brian perry brian check this out you
know why you're perfect to shout out
on a star wars related video ch check
the everyone everyone check this out
guys everyone's everyone around
to check this out
it is generally thought to be a celtic
origin the name brian but its meaning is
disputed
some believe check everyone shall decide
it is to be derived from the root bree
meaning
force
it's strength
but mainly the keyword force because you
know it's star wars it's about forcing
people to do things they don't want to
do
um that's why they say may the force be
with you meaning assert yourself and
create dominance and power
will yourself into situations and get
things from people without their
permission force may the force be with
you
so that's what the word in mind
or
i think we should go with force and
strength i think that's much better
so
yeah man that's a that's a good name
meaning
you are the spirit of the force you are
one with the force brian that's
beautiful dude you're you are forced in
strength and you give us
strength
by
allowing by being supportive at our
patron allowing us to because that
patrol helps us hire people to do stuff
you're a big help like a wandering help
guy but stop forcing yourself to
do things you don't want to do i almost
want to wait to for joe it's a face
no
no bryce not brian thanks for being here
ryan's on that kind of force guy yeah
brian's a consent
[Music]